en este terreno baldío en el barrio
ferroviario de yaundé comenzó su carrera
a gael en ganan wheat ex jugadora de
camerún y balón de oro africano en 2015
en la actualidad aquí entrenan las
alumnas de la academia rails la primera
escuela de fútbol femenino del país es
creada por la estrella hace tres años
[Música]
and joy vi todas las dificultades que
tuve que soportar cuando era muy pequeña
hacer deporte con niños no estar cómoda
a veces ser la única niña hoy con mi
academia ellas tienen la oportunidad de
trabajar entre ellas entre las mujeres
porque es la posibilidad de huawei
elephant aquí dos veces por semana unos
cincuenta alumnos provenientes de
entornos son desfavorecidos son
capacitadas a un alto nivel todas sueñan
con el destino de una campeona a cuerda
academia después de la academia espero
llegar a el mismo nivel que su fundador
a ganar trofeos ser la mejor jugadora de
áfrica o europa
me gustaría representar a mi país y
jugar en un acampe meninas me
enorgullecería el entrenamiento es
gratuito está bien supervisado y las
niñas se reciben todo el equipo
deportivo argumentos que han convencido
a muchos padres del barrio reacios a
dejar que su hija juega al fútbol en un
país donde el fútbol femenino aún se
está desarrollando
me dije a mí mismo una niña debe ir a la
escuela porque no ser médica porque no
ser abogada al principio yo era muy y mi
hija porque no que juegue con las leonas
indomables porque no se reclutará en
europa
europa a largo plazo de él en gana with
desea convertir su academia en un
internado para dar la oportunidad de las
pequeñas de tomar el relevo de las
leones indomables actuales